all right I know I have a hole in my
sweater I should not have raised my hand
raised Mansi do you know what it's from
it's from working out working out of it
up you know what happened what so I was
in the greenroom before and I said this
is Gregg sweater did the Prince kill
Khashoggi maybe he did maybe he didn't
that's from Trump causing today's hair
burning media freak out which happens
whenever Trump tells the blunt truth
about a policy we were okay with well
before him so now you're pissed off over
the Saudis after decades of human rights
abuses and terror enabling this is what
gets your goat according to Ben Rhodes
in 2009 when Obama went to Riyadh the
Saudi Kings gave each staffer a pile of
jewels and the first couple got a
hundred thousand pounds worth of baubles
which were accepted and then sent to the
National Archives that beats a washer
dryer on prices right but even back then
we knew Saudi Arabia they were different
but they were allies and allies can suck
so maybe the boss's son had Khashoggi
offed or maybe not which is it think
hard it's a card game if you say the
prince is guilty you're committing poker
suicide by folding while holding all the
best cards sure playing your moral ace
might please everyone in the media but
winning their approval wins America
nothing it's just wastes a great
opportunity but hold off and say maybe
maybe not maybe not you come out ahead
and the pot you want to win impacts your
country's happiness if you spent your
life playing this game
keeping your cards close and waiting you
know America has the Saudis over a
barrel millions of barrels really and in
negotiations that means you can get
something big from them that you
couldn't get before like what Middle
East progress a chance for peace in
Palestine and Israel the ability to
influence oil prices who knows for sure
it will be more than a pile of dumb
jewels all right Dana this is another
example of what I say we'll see what
happens
what who Trump is gone we'll see what
happens like if the Saudis don't offer
America something really big then he can
go back in six months and say they
killed that guy he can't hurt
got that option right maybe you're not
what your explanation point was the one
I was like girl but that's how we talked
right okay look your friends can
sometimes make it really hard to defend
them tell me about it okay I know what
they're talking about but no that's a
thing it's a obviously it's a complex
situation the end result was maybe
always going to be this yeah okay but
then the way the statement reads that
communications is important right yeah
maybe he's speaking to a certain
audience but you're speaking to lots of
different audiences all at once and then
the tweet today Murray says oil prices
getting lower
great and he thanked Saudi Arabia for
that yeah over a barrel
maybe that shoes on the other foot and
if oil prices were the real intention
making the tough decision to get out of
the Iran deal would have been the wrong
one if oil prices are the real intention
I don't think I don't think it is but
right because it's complex it is but
that doesn't say that in these tweets
and that is a tough thing I think that
human rights is in our national
Security's interest I think this is
obviously very difficult I also feel
like the president could have gotten
more out of this you're saying that
Saudi we should get something out of
this but why would they why would we get
anything now when he's already said
everything's cool no I think he's
working on I think well maybe so maybe
behind the scenes but wouldn't it have
been great if we haven't found out today
that Saudi had released all the women
that they had put into tension because
they had the temerity to get out there
and and and drive before the regulations
were allowed or maybe like all these
other things that we could have asked
for them to do from a Human Rights
sample I think our national security
interests are our national security
interests right so that's a harlot
that's a hard reality or stuff out of
him that's how hard I think that's what
I think what we're going for is
something in the Middle East that's
bigger bigger than oil they say the same
thing about Russia and Vladimir Putin we
know he's going to be a helpful I would
use North Korea as an example and now
he's saying that but the fact is Greg
it's not about our national interest to
have our morals our principles that's
general I mean you're looking at this
part of this hang on let me finish we're
saying to people who are dictators and
who are murderers but you know what you
can do business with us it's all
transactional as long as you promise us
more
and more oil but hey wait a second it's
not true he says it's 350 billion
dollars tens of thousands of jobs every
fact checker in America said that's not
true the transaction is one side we are
saying to them you know what go right
ahead and to me that is it's
unacceptable great you know what I
here's the way I look at it see if he
took he took the hard way out he could
have hurt you signaled and making all of
you guys happy but he didn't he doesn't
need to satisfy morning blow you know
instead he embraces the role of the cold
hard parent who was right if you just
focus on this one incident and blow the
future it doesn't make sense well when
you look at what is happening right now
in Washington there are a lot of
lawmakers who are saying you know we
want sanctions yeah
on 12 people who are slated to be killed
the president says you want sanctions
Congress didn't pass sanctions right
right I think I heard Rush Limbaugh on
the on the radio yesterday say something
about you know people in Europe are
saying well what's the president gonna
do we're waiting on him to do something
well why doesn't Europe and their arms
sales which it's like and that's not
necessary in their best interest either
it's not in your best interest for a
country that you need in the Middle East
to not buy your weapons you want them to
buy your weapon right but so what is the
president gonna do I think he's doing it
he's a businessman I think ultimately
how many times have you heard
businessmen say it's nothing personal
yeah it's just business yeah and in this
case it's America's business I think he
could have done that I agree with you
that he looked at it from the
perspective of a businessman I think he
could have done that though and made the
statement better had he done the very
same thing that he did but within that
statement been harder when it came to
the murder of a journalist be less
tolerant of that not see there were
there were there were angles of this
statement where he almost seemed like he
was taking the Saudi crown prince's
version of the story over the
intelligence community and what they're
they're finding you can't do that so if
he wants to maintain that this is a
strategic Ally if he wants to come at it
from the angle of the businessman I
think that's all okay to an extent but
you have to acknowledge that there's a
whole bunch of people looking at this
that want them
message sent that if if if a regime
violates human rights extensively they
expect an American president to have a
reaction to that that's substantial and
makes you feel like you know what he
cares about our economic interest but he
also cares about the values the whole
country is bill agrees with you Turkey
and you know I'm so happy to see Turkey
come out against human rights abuse yeah
and come after us over that but you know
what it's not just Turkey I mean you
could say that's a lot of turkeys but
there's especially the same every year
but what strikes me is the number of
Republicans yeah and normally with
President Trump being as popular as he
is among Republicans you don't see the
the Senate and the Congress yeah step up
to him but what we're seeing is Marco
Rubio Rand Paul Lindsey Graham bob
corker Jeff Flake I mean these guys are
saying this is wrong we are Americans we
stand for human rights yet I wish they
had a broader perspective but oh well